en el resto de esta lección nos vamos a
encontrar con algunos otros problemas de
hacer cuentas que surgen cuando queremos
hacer una gran multitud a partir de un
conjunto pequeño de partes vamos a
construir una fórmula muy poderosa a la
que podemos considerar como una
herramienta para contar para empezar
vamos a imaginarnos unos robots que
parezcan serpientes y llamémosles
serpiente robots están construidas como
una secuencia de segmentos pero cada
segmento se debe de utilizar exactamente
una vez por ejemplo si estoy
construyendo una serpiente robot de tres
segmentos puede ser que ensambla los
segmentos de esta forma o lo puedo hacer
de esta otra forma y nuevamente nos
gustaría saber cuántas de estas
serpientes robot puedo construir pero
recuerda tenemos que tomar en cuenta
todas las posibilidades en el próximo
ejercicio vas a tener que construir
todas las posibles serpientes robots de
longitud desde un segmento hasta
segmentos así es que reconstruye las